there was this little thing called
e-commerce and what they did was they
allowed
amazon to run that business for them
when it was just a little thing
and you have to be very careful about
the little things that you
outsource that may someday become
big things unbelievable they they
taught amazon they brought amazon into
the business they
made their biggest competitors in toys r
us case they really created their own
downfall
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures
hippo insurance opposed hillel at
stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about the amazon way
with john rossmann author of the amazon
way and managing partner of rosman
partners
john is the author of the amazon way
book series a former amazon leader and
managing partner at rosman partners
john is an expert leveraging the amazon
leadership principles to help others
innovate
compete and win in the digital era john
was an executive at amazon.com where he
played a key role in launching the
amazon marketplace business
as the director of merchant integration
and went on to have responsibilities for
the enterprise business at amazon
welcome john john rossman welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
michael thanks for having me i'm great
doing great
well thank you very very much for taking
the time to be here i'm i'm really
excited to
hone in on your journey as an innovator
and a critical thinker
on you know on an enterprise level on a
global level
and previously an executive and director
within amazon dealing with some
incredible enterprise clients like
target and sears
and uh now you're also an you know an
innovative i guess coach or advisor
to to a variety of companies you wrote a
book called the amazon way
talking about some principles in
leadership from amazon and i'm really
excited to hear about that as well
john walk me through before we get into
those principles walk me a little bit
through your career
and how you end up as an innovator
thinker
yeah so uh i studied engineering in
school i was
always interested in solving problems in
particular like
integration how do you integrate systems
data
processes cultures organizations
business models like that i kept going
up the stack
from an integration standpoint i uh
was at a small technology company early
in
in 2000 and a former colleague of mine
from amazon
said hey you got to come over and talk
to us about an initiative we're thinking
about
so after several interviews i got the
opportunity
in early 2002 to go to amazon help
lead the marketplace launch
um in 2002 so today that business is
over 50
of all units shipped and sold at amazon
so
we launched the marketplace in late 2002
i ran that for a couple of years and
then i went to run
enterprise services at amazon so we ran
target.com
amazon uh toys r us a bunch of other
great brands
and i left amazon in late 2005.
i have to get into john and just share
with you that recently
in the stanford one of my stanford
classes we actually did a case study
and we were studying you know the how
amazon was working with target on
building the marketplace
and i think so so now i'm now i'm
matching the face
i'd love to see those materials and see
kind of the uh
factual uh what fact versus fiction
aspects of that
that was a complex relationship
and um but i think it's one with the
lesson behind that between
from both target and toys r us is
there was this little thing called
e-commerce and what they did was they
allowed amazon to run that business for
them when it was just a little thing
and you have to be very careful about
the little things that you
outsource that may someday become
big things unbelievable they
they taught amazon they brought amazon
into the business they made
their biggest competitors in toys r us
case they really created their own
downfall
through that relationship and so it's a
it's a
it's a interesting story of being
careful about
the future and things that may seem
really small but are actually the future
of the business
um back then did you have did you
personally have an idea
you know of what's happening here
because obviously today we can look back
and we're thinking how the hell did they
do that
and but but back then what was that like
well
um to some degree yes because
all you had to do was do the math right
so
e-commerce at that point was was growing
at ten to twenty percent a year but it
was
only one to two percent of the business
but general retail was only growing one
to two percent of the year
so you just had to do the math and you
go i don't know how long but this is
going to be a big
um a big business and the other thing
like we intrinsically knew was
it's a better customer experience it's a
complimentary customer experience
and over time the it's going to get
better the infrastructure is going to
get better the
the the browsing experience is going to
get better we
mobility wasn't even a thing at that
point
and and so we absolutely knew that
that we were the fox and the hen house
right like we got
invited in to run this business but we
were
we really couldn't believe that they had
allowed that to happen
right and so just for the context which
is definitely important back then
target and i and i i know and i learned
also toys r us
actually contracted amazon to run their
e-commerce business
so so here's how ridiculous it was if
back in 2000 2001 if you went to
toysrus.com
you actually went to a branded amazon
website page so so so they they
gave the whole customer experience
uh away and that's how
short-sighted that relationship
was wow well
it's it's gonna go down in history as
one of those bigger plays that
we all need to learn about and now i
understand also your fascination with
innovation because that this is a part
of
the story of innovation right it really
is and i think
you know amazon is i believe
the most interesting company in the
digital era and they're
digital era for a few reasons first
is they have created the most
complex but really well integrated sets
of different business models right they
they they have the retail business the
marketplace slightly different than the
retail business they have a private
labels business
they have aws they have kindle they have
the their content business multiple
content businesses
but they actually are highly integrated
together both
from a customer experience standpoint as
well as from an operating leverage
standpoint
and amazon is both a
world-class operator and a systematic
innovator and it's understanding
that those are two different playbooks
most people go oh i'm a good operator i
can be a good innovator it's like
the the very things you do as a good
operator typically squash being an
innovator
and so the most of the work i do is with
medium to large companies and how do you
complement
the great business the great operating
skills you have
with an an actual thoughtful growth
agenda and in an innovation process to
be a systematic innovator
and so looking at horizon 2 and horizon
3 beyond your horizon 1 business models
that's the work i do and it's
fascinating to see when
the light bulbs start going on of like
what we need to do
one of the things that takes though is
that yeah you have to
be willing to to not optimize
for today's profitability for this
quarter
and that again something amazon has
demonstrated time and time again
they are more than willing to sacrifice
this quarter's profits this year's
profits to
to invest and create tomorrow's
businesses and that's again another
reason why i think they are
the most interesting company in the
digital era and then the the last reason
i think they're the most
the interesting company in the digital
era is they're so crystal clear
about how they do things internally and
so
it's that the what they're doing is
interesting to me but it's the
why and the how they do it that is the
real story
they operate with the same mechanisms
the same
principles now that they did when i was
then
it was there and so that consistency of
how they work
has allowed them to become a massive
company without
becoming a bureaucracy without slowing
down and
that is the story that i captured in the
amazon way
is what's the unlock how do we
take some of these principles and some
of these mechanisms
and insert them into our business
incredible and so as you're sitting
today
with one of your small and medium
businesses and you're thinking through
these principles
what are some trends that are coming up
that i as a young entrepreneur can take
with me on my journey as i'm thinking
about operations
innovation everything in between you
know
from your experience well two consistent
patterns
it varies situation but two consistent
patterns first is
gaining clarity of thought on what we're
proposing to do
and most organizations they they develop
a powerpoint they
they have a general notion of what
they're going to do
but they're actually talking past each
other on a number of
important points it could be the value
proposition
it could be how we are going to test and
evaluate something
it's it's really the clarity of what we
are proposing to do
amazon has some great mechanisms things
they do to help
get that type of clarity and it really
starts with the
the writing skills right writing
narratives writing future press releases
writing
frequently asked questions before you
commit to an endeavor so that we think
through it so much better and that
the teams that are working this and the
decision makers actually
have a simple and clear and consistent
understanding of
this is what we envision doing and how
we do it and then the second pattern
that comes up
is really in establishing
our goals relative to you know either
this initiative or
our business in general the 14th
leadership principle at amazon
is deliver results and what they talk
about
is that we focus on controllable
inputs to achieve the outputs that we
want
most organizations spend most of their
time talking about the outputs
financial outputs market share outputs
other types of gains what they don't
focus on what they don't get
clarity on is the controllable inputs
what are we going to
do in order to get to those
outputs and so there's there's a lot of
tools you can do okrs objectives key
results is one framework that can be
really helpful
but but most teams aren't willing to
have the debate
and spend the time in really carefully
dissecting
this is how i think i am going to
achieve
the output that i want and so just
slowing them down
and forcing them to really have
debatable um moments
of how we are going to achieve an output
again it's about clarity of thought
before we
enter the initiative i think is one of
amazon's real superpowers and something
that i work with
a lot of my clients on so how does
one from experience keep themselves in
check as they're
you know asking am i being innovative am
i am i fostering a culture where i'm
able to have these intellectual debates
whether i'm able
to foster in a culture where people can
gain clarity and be very intentional
about what they do
it sounds like that that is something
that amazon has achieved but how can
leaders keep themselves in check with
that
yeah i think one one thing to do is
really just have a portfolio
understanding of your initiatives the
things you are doing
and if you think about a portfolio that
measures
on one access potential benefit on the
other access potential risk
and what most companies are good at is
that lower left hand quadrant
low low risk low reward
essentially these are the things we
understand really well
and if we execute well we know what sort
of return we should get on it
what most companies aren't good at and
they they
they gloss over is that upper right hand
quadrant
high risk high reward that's where you
have to have a different playbook
but most companies don't even understand
that there is a portfolio relative to
your initiative
you have to recognize those upper right
hand quadrant
moments those are bets we think it's a
good idea
but we don't know for sure so the key
thing you have to do is you have to test
it right that's the whole minimally
viable product
agile mindset but especially in bigger
companies
like their their their whole institution
is built around how to make things that
should be small and testable
into really big monolithic
uh requirements laden
process laden moments and projects
and so that's where we need a different
playbook in order to make those
really testable moments so keep yourself
in check by having a portfolio view
of the initiatives that you're doing
amazing
so the the amazon way you recently
launched the book
what are some other interesting case
studies that you're that you're
examining from
you know amazon is a company that you
know i as a young entrepreneur can
can look back and say wow this is
something really cool and it's not
really trivial to
to to know that this is how they did it
well
a couple of the things that so this is
actually the the third edition of the
book
pretty significant revision uh tom
alberg
who uh was on the board at amazon for 23
years
founder of madrona venture capital wrote
the forward for the book so
so that alone is a worthwhile
uh short read but he really talks about
like these
these principles are real to amazon and
he's seen where they can be real to
others
i wrote a preface uh for the book and
i really took it as a strategy exercise
if i were to make one recommendation
amazon what would the recommendation be
you have to understand where amazon
comes from the past 25 years
they've been they came from a scrappy
doubted
um entrepreneurial organization and they
still have some of that scrappiness
in them interesting they've they've won
the game right like just
concede the game to them i think they
need to think about a new leadership
principle that prioritizes
other stakeholders other than customers
other than shareholders
stakeholders like brands like
employees like the communities that they
live in
and and change at amazon starts with the
leadership principles so it's really
it's not a criticism it's a it's a
strategic perspective for them
because they do have things to address
in
bezos last shareholder letter he's
pretty clear about
one of them which is you know we need to
do a better job at
the employee experience and employee
safety and he stated a mission for that
so they have some things to address but
they also there's a there's a narrative
out there
about big tech and they are in general
losing that narrative and so i think the
the the jujitsu move would be if you
restated a leadership principle that
said we are going to be better than the
best relative to being a stakeholder in
the community at whole
i think that would help reset the
narrative both internally and externally
and um and then i wrote a new appendix
in the book i've worked with so many
companies on
building their leadership principles
and so i wrote an appendix about
building your own leadership principles
again what most companies want to do is
they want to rush through it right like
okay let's have a retreat
we declare our leadership principles and
then they're off with it
you have to take time with these things
i always i talk about in the book you
have to etch them in jello right
create a draft live with them see how
you really practice them
and then be willing to come back to it
and revisit it
principles are about culture and
cultures about the little things you do
every day that create patterns and great
outcomes
in a company and that's what these
leadership principles do for amazon
so the key for anybody who wants to
to have a consistent culture of how we
debate
things how we hold each other
accountable how we make decisions
is you have to think about a practical
set of tenants or principles or rules
whatever you want to call them
but then you got to practice them you're
not going to get it right
the first time and it takes time for
these
patterns these tools to be replicated
across your organization
amazing john thank you so much for
coming and for sharing your insights and
and this really is closing a circle for
me from from that stanford class i i
really appreciate it but i have a few
more questions not about amazon but
about you
and i want to take you back to your
childhood and i want to know what really
fascinated you as a kid
well i would say that the the things
that had the biggest
impact on me as a kid and fascinated me
was i loved
team sports i i loved the nature
of having a common goal and
a group of people that although you knew
that like that you had different roles
you
you you know in different skills you
were there to achieve a goal
and i loved the the practice like the
hard
work you had to do in order to achieve a
goal
and coaches you know my athletic coaches
were really some of the biggest
influencers in in
in in my life and so that was
really the things i prized from my
childhood
were typically about the the teams that
i got to be part of
amazing and inspiration today what
inspires you on a daily basis
well um you know what inspires me i like
i like
being a practical strategist and problem
solver still right like i love
not being the expert in the business
that that separation
the fresh set of eyes is is
90 of the time a real asset for me it's
it um
i'm working with a team i'm working with
a client they have the expertise
but i have a i have a fresh set of eyes
i can i can ask different questions i
can challenge assumptions
and i can step back and see things and i
love
when when we work together and we come
up with a new
observation relative to you know the
business how we work together how they
achieved and so
so i i am so fortunate to get to do the
type of work that i get to do today
and um that's those are the best moments
when you know together you really have
an unlock
an insight that that they didn't have
before
amazing and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i i i'm pretty energetic i have a
tough time
sitting still so i like having variety
uh in my activities and in the work i do
um i'm a strategist and i always try to
approach
things not just from a short-term basis
but from a long-term basis and
how do you create multiples of wins and
not just
um a one-off win and i think i'm a
clarifier
right we talked about kind of gaining
clarity and a couple of my long-term
partners have
they've always commented to me like john
what you're always doing with a group
is you're working to simplify and
clarify
what they're doing what they're working
on what they're saying and i
and i and and and i think it's because
i'm honestly struggling most of time to
like understand it myself i just have to
force them to say it in a simpler more
consistent
clear way so that i actually understand
it so i always say like i'm the idiot
test here right and
and we're not done until i truly get it
but again that's the combination that
helps make it effective
john thank you so so much really really
interesting insights and i really
appreciate you coming here and
thank you for thank you for the
inspiration and continue making a
positive impact with a lot of the
companies you're working on and i'm
looking forward to reaching out for
advice
with my own company that i'll start on
on how to build a culture of innovation
and be very deliberate and intentional
about that so thank you very much
well best of luck to you and your
endeavors and thanks for inviting me
you